Hariri is gone but the demonstrators
remain thousands stayed on the street
into the night at the main protest camp
close to the Prime Minister's
headquarters they see her Aires
resignation as a victory but for them it
is just the first step of the war we
need that change we need we start with
the with the with the government the
bigger change with it will be with the
establishment protesters celebrated the
moment of the first big change to that
political system Prime Minister Hariri
announced to the nation that he was
stepping down I am going to the
presidential palace to submit the
government's resignation to President
Michelle Arun and people in all regions
in response to the will of the many
Lebanese people who have taken to the
streets to demand change
allas ahead late album Tahrir but there
are powerful forces in Lebanon who are
against the change the protesters are
demanding before Hariri announced his
resignation supporters of the Shiite
Muslim political movements Hezbollah and
Amal rampaged through the main protest
camp it was the worst violence since
protests started nearly two weeks ago
activists are back at that camp on our
determined to continue their fight her
Ares departure has lifted their spirits
but it may not be enough to end the
country's turmoil the protests in
Lebanon were triggered by a tax plan
that has since been withdrawn the
demonstrators may be angry at the
current government but the country's
problems are much deeper in much older
there's the country's struggling economy
Lebanon is deeply in debt and youth
unemployment is at 37% the failing
economy is putting pressure on public
services their chronic problems with
electricity the water supply and garbage
collection another big issue is
corruption Lebanon is ranked 138 out of
180 on transparency international's
corruption index and the country's
intricate sectarian political system
only complicates matters Lebanon's
political system mirrors sectarian
divisions in the country the rules
dictate that every major religion is
represented but critics say that builds
sectarian divisions into the fabric of
government DW correspondent Bassel
aready is in Lebanon's capital Beirut
and joins us now
so the protesters say they are fed up
with governments with the Lebanon
sectarian form of government what are
they offering or what are they proposing
as an alternative they don't have any
offer in fact we have demands they are
asking the government the new government
the caretaker government to establish
new laws civil laws and the Parliament
as well to have a constitutional
amendments regarding the two issues the
government the governmental and para
mental works will lead to a civil state
according to the protesters that's why
they are still taking the squares in
West Bend down't
town Beirut and some other major cities
to follow up all these
package okay the the protesters have
managed to achieve one thing that gotten
the resignation of the president
president Hariri has stepped back what
impact is his resignation likely to have
on the on the protest movement the
resignation was looped by all the
protesters and they said that they
achieved a victory according to the
protesters it's the first victory they
are asking for two more things
the little electorial new low a new
electoral law and early elections and to
take down the sectarian regime this
issue the alpha for the process they
knew it
they know that it's a long process they
can't be achieved within 13 or 14 days
it's a long process that's why they are
asking for primitive the new government
would demo some new government that lead
to to form these new laws to have their
to form the civil state
okay now things turn quite violent in
Beirut there yesterday how belittle is
the situation right now Basel the army
now is asking the protester on the main
roads
main highways in Lebanon to quit this
rose
or otherwise he will open it by force be
some some protesters or some leaders in
this process they are all their
colleagues on the highways and roads to
quit and move out of these trees to
because they first of all they will stay
actually the first demand the
resignation of the government so now
they can open this resort to somehow to
regain the economic social and political
life and move a little bit faster
especially that we have all male it's
kind of you know it's like all on roads
blocked the back exactly too close since
14 days now the
first time that happened in four in the
recent history of Lebanon Paso thank you
very much for bringing us up-to-date
there that was correspondent basilar
really in Beirut thank you